>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO TUCKER CARLSON "TUCKR
WELCOME TO TUCKER CARLSON "TUCKC
WELCOME TO TUCKER CARLSON "TUCKS
WELCOME TO TUCKER CARLSON "TUCKN
TONIGHT."
THE PRESIDENT WILL ADDRESS
THE NATION A LITTLE OVER AN
HOUR FROM NOW.
HE WILL MAKE THE CASE FOR A
PROTECTIVE WAR ALONG OUR
SOUTHERN BORDER.
THEN HE WILL BROADLY ARGUE
THAT OUR IMMIGRATION
PROBLEMS ARE REAL.
NOT A FIGMENT OF OUR
IMAGINATION.
THEY ARE HURTING THE COUNTRY
BADLY.
THE PRESIDENT WILL FAIL THAT
IN A FEW MINUTES.
HE WILL NOT GO UNCHALLENGED
THE NEWS MEDIA AND
OPERATIVES.
THEY ARE NOT WAITING FOR
9:00 P.M. TO DO IT.
THEY ARE UP EARLY EVERY DAY
WAITING FOR THE SAME SET OF
TALKING POINTS.
TODAY'S SLOGAN IS SIMPLE.
DON'T BELIEVE YOUR OWN EYES,
NONE OF THIS IS REAL.
EVERYTHING IS JUST FINE.
>> IT IS SALUTE
>> IT IS AALUTE
>> IT IS ABSUTE
>> IT IS ABSOLE
>> IT IS ABSOLUTE FICTION
THAT THERE IS A NATIONAL
EMERGENCY HERE.
>> SHOWING THIS IS NOT ABOUT
A CRISIS.
IT'S A POLITICAL PLOY.
>> CRISIS, CRISIS.
IT'S A CRISIS THAT DOESN'T
EXIST.
>> THEY'RE TRYING TO CREATE
THE NOTION THAT THERE IS AN
EMERGENCY AND SOMETHING
SHOULD BE DONE IMMEDIATELY
TO PREVENT IT.
THERE IS NO EMERGENCY ON THE
SOUTHERN BORDER.
>> BEING FROM NEW JERSEY, I
KNOW NATIONAL EMERGENCIES,
YOU KNOW, WE HAVE SEEN SUPER
STORM SANDY.
WE HAVE SEEN 9/11.
THIS IS NOT A NATIONAL
EMERGENCY AND CERTAINLY.
>> THIS NATIONAL EMERGENCY
IS COMPLETELY MADE UP.
>> A WALL IS A COLLOSAL
WASTE OF MONEY FOR A CRISIS
THAT DOESN'T EXIST.
>> EVEN IF HE DECLARES A
NATIONAL EMERGENCY, HE'S
LYING.
EVEN IF HE DECLARES IT, IT
WILL BE A DECLARATION OF A
FALSEHOOD.
>> THIS WHOLE IDEA OF
DECLARING A NATIONAL
EMERGENCY IS LUDICROUS
BECAUSE THERE ISN'T ONE.
>> Tucker: SO REPEAT AFTER
ME, NO NATIONAL EMERGENCY.
THE CRISIS AT THE BORDER IS
FAKE.
IT'S FRAUDULENT.
IT'S TOTALLY MADE UP.
THINK LEPRECHAUNS OR LOW-CAL
ICE CREAM.
SOMETHING ONLY KIDS AND DUMB
PEOPLE BELIEVE.
IN DO YOU KNOW WHAT THE
BORDER CRISIS IS LIKE LIKE
THAT IMAGINARY CARAVAN FROM
HONDURAS A FEW MONTHS AGO
THE ONE THAT MARCHED TO
TIJUANA WITH TV CAMERAS IN
TOW BUT DIDN'T REALLY EXIST.
>> THEY ARE TELLING YOU THAT
THE EXISTENTIAL THREAT TO
AMERICA IS A BUNCH OF POOR
REFUGEES A THOUSAND MILES
AWAY.
THIS GROUP OF FOLKS?
WE DON'T EVEN KNOW WHERE
THEY ARE.
THEY ARE WAY DOWN THERE.
>> THEY HAVE BEEN RUNNING ON
AN IMAGINARY CARAVAN.
>> THIS STUPID [BLEEP]
CARAVAN.
[LAUGHTER]
YOU KNOW, IT'S A LIE THAT
THIS CARAVAN IS A PROBLEM OF
THAT MAGNITUDE.
>> PROGRAMMING ON THE
CARAVAN WAS PROPAGANDA.
>> Tucker: YEP, CARAVAN'S
FAKE, TOO.
BREATHE EASY, AMERICA, A LOT
OF THE PROBLEMS YOU HAVE
BEEN WORRIED ABOUT DON'T
NEED SOLUTIONS BECAUSE THEY
ARE NOT REAL.
THAT'S WHAT THE MEDIA ARE
TELLING US ABOUT ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION AND A LOT OF
OTHER THINGS AND IT'S A
RELIEF.
BUT IT DOES LEAVE AT LEAST
ONE BIG QUESTION UNANSWERED.
IF NONE OF THIS IS REALLY
HAPPENING, WHY DOES SO MANY
PEOPLE THINK THAT IT IS?
HOW ARE MILLIONS OF
AMERICANS EXPERIENCING THE
SAME HALLUCINATION AT THE
SAME TIME?
AND THE ANSWER, OF COURSE
IS.
IT'S ALLUSION.
AMERICANS ARE BEING TRICKED.
TRICKED BY THAT DASTARDLY
FOX NEWS AND THOSE
DEMAGOGUES IN PRIME TIME WHO
WON'T SHUT UP DESPITE BEING
WARNED REPEATEDLY BY THE
AUTHORITIES TO BE QUIET IF
YOU KNOW WHAT'S GOOD FOR
YOU.
SHADOWY SABOTEURS PLAYED A
ROLE AS WELL THEY ALWAYS DO.
THE "NEW YORK TIMES" RAN A
PIECE THE OTHER DAY
EXPLAINING THAT DONALD TRUMP
ONLY SUPPORTS A BORDER WALL
BECAUSE ROGER STONE TOLD HIM
TO.
IT WAS PART OF A POLITICAL
PLOY.
STONE, MEANWHILE, NOW
APPEARS TO BE CAUGHT UP IN
THE RUSSIA INVESTIGATION AND
THAT MAKES SOME SENSE IF YOU
THINK ABOUT IT.
DONALD TRUMP'S ELECTION AND
A WALL ON THE MEXICAN
BORDER.
NOBODY IN WASHINGTON COULD
IMAGINE WANTING EITHER ONE
OF THOSE THINGS OR FOR THAT
MATTER IMAGINING ANYONE ELSE
IN AMERICA WANTING THEM.
SO THERE HAS TO BE A SECRET
CABAL PUSHING THIS CRAP.
VLADIMIR PUTIN, ROGER STONE,
FOX NEWS, THEY ARE ALL IN IT
TOGETHER SOMEHOW.
MAYBE ROBERT MUELLER WILL
GET TO THE BOTTOM OF IT.
THAT'S HONESTLY HOW PEOPLE
IN WASHINGTON THINK.
TRUST US, WE LIVE HERE.
OF COURSE IT'S COMPLETELY
DELUSIONAL, DEMINTED
ACTUALLY.
ONCE YOU UNDERSTAND WHERE
THESE PEOPLE ARE COMING
FROM, IT'S HARD TO BLAME
THEM FOR CONSTRUCTING THESE
FANTASIES.
THE NEXT TIME YOU SEE SOME
ANGRY FACE ON CNN SHOUTING
ABOUT THIS OR THAT,
REMEMBER, THIS PERSON ISN'T
ARGUING FOR CHANGE.
THIS PERSON IS ARGUING FOR
MORE OF THE SAME, ARGUING
FOR A PERMANENT EXTENSION OF
THE WAY THINGS ARE.
THEY MAY CLAIM THEY ARE MAD
ABOUT TRUMP OR THE WALL OR
WHATEVER, NAME THE TOPIC,
BUT THOSE ARE JUST SYMPTOMS
OF THE LARGER PROBLEM, THE
THING THEY FEAR MOST.
AND THAT IS AN ASSAULT ON
THE STATUS QUO.
THEY LIKE THE STATUS QUO.
THEY ARE DEEPLY VESTED IN
THE STATUS QUO.
THIS IS THE GROUP THAT'S
BECOME RICHER AND HAPPIER
SINCE THE FINANCIAL CRISIS
OF 2008.
THERE AREN'T A LOT OF THOSE
PEOPLE IN AMERICA.
MOST OF THEM LIVE IN A
HANDFUL OF BIG CITIES.
A LOT OF THEM SEEM TO HAVE
CABLE TELEVISION CONTRACTS
SOMEHOW.
AND WHAT THIS GROUP FEARS
MOST IS THAT SOME IDIOT WILL
COME ALONG, ASK A BUNCH OF
UNCOMFORTABLE QUESTIONS AND
WRECK WHAT HAS TURNED OUT TO
BE A VERY GOOD DEAL FOR
THEM
LOW WORK, HIGH PAYING JOBS,
CHEAP HOUSEHOLD HELP.
LEAFY STABLE NEIGHBORHOODS
THAT LOOK LIKE IT'S 1965 AND
CORRUPT AND INSULAR SYSTEM
OF HIGHER EDUCATION THAT'S
ESSENTIALLY CLOSED TO
OUTSIDERS THAT CAN BE RELIED
UPON TO KEEP THIS WHOLE SCAM
GOING IN PERPETUITY.
WHAT YOU ARE REALLY LOOKING
AT HERE IS A SELF-SATISFIED
ARISTOCRACIES.
ALL OF THOSE ARE THE SAME.
WHAT THEY FEAR MOST IS A
CHALLENGE TO THE WAY THINGS
ARE.
KEEP THAT IN MIND TONIGHT AS
YOU WATCH THEIR RESPONSE.
WE DON'T NEED WALLS, THEY